my name is Peter Brooks and I just want
to say
two minutes worth of introduction to
this conference
the questions that we come together to
discuss today
very often grew out of the experience of
prison teaching for me and for many of
the others who are here
in my case of course I taught at East
Jersey State Prison in Rahway New Jersey
a few years ago which was for me an
absolutely transformative experience
to experience as an outsider the reality
of the inside of prison and the way it
has affected so many lives in our
country is to confront directly the way
we as as a society as a country have
created the monster of mass
incarceration
how is this shaped inner life public
spectacle moral possibilities what needs
to be thought and said about
incarceration
what do the literature and Arch of
incarceration and of the incarcerated
have to say to us how does incarceration
haunt even those outside of Prison Walls
what are the stakes of the prison
education movement these are all
questions or among the questions we're
going to think about here
since I teach literature I began to
think about the place and image of
prison in the public mind and in works
of literature and art going back at
least to the enlightenment especially to
the work of cesare bekaria who published
his on crimes and punishments in 1764 if
you will the the very beginning of the
prison reform movement and of other
poets novelist dramatists artists
composers who have meditated on
incarceration and the human mind I think
if standal Silvio pelico Alexandra Dumas
Dickens Victor Hugo Dostoevsky gramshi
and also Beethoven in his one Opera
Fidelio
the French Revolution you remember kicks
off with an attack on an Infamous prison
the Bastille which then symbolically is
demolished Stone by Stone
I think prison has become the punitive
Shadow to all the major in uh
institutions of our society we live in
that shadow but we also possibly believe
in the promise as one of my students at
East Jersey put it of turning prison
into a university a grand aspiration
towards the transformation of the
carceral space this country has created
into a place of learning and creativity
that brings us together today at least
that is the hope that brings us together
today
so we're going to move at once to uh the
first panel but before I do that I want
to just speak a quick word of thanks to
those who have brought this Symposium
into being
it was originally to have been at the
Eric Holder Center at Columbia Law
School two and a half years ago it was
canceled because of covid
it was planned along with my good
friends Bernard Harcourt who is here
today and Matthew spelberg who is in
Alaska and couldn't be here today uh
transferred to Yale the Symposium
happily found a new a new new
collaborators
Richard Weisberg and the law and
Humanities Foundation that he directs
Judith Resnick and the Arthur Lyman
Center for public interest law that she
created at the Yale law school and
Dwayne Betts and his freedom reads
program and the Whitney Humanity Center
where it found his present home thanks
to Alice Kaplan the director and Diane
Brown the assistant director and their
remarkable staff including Megan
O'Donnell and a number of others
so thanks said and that's really a small
thanks for the great work that they've
done on this I'm going to turn things
over to Emily bazelon who's too well
known to you all to need uh introduction
among her many honors and attributes
fortunately for us she's a lecturer and
and Senior research fellow at the law
school Emily
Peter
um it is such a pleasure to be here with
all of you for this long anticipated
exciting event which has so much
interdisciplinary richness to offer
um I'm really excited for uh to do a lot
of listening and maybe just a little bit
of talking this morning
um I
I don't know is this working they're all
on okay good thank you
um that's okay thanks Rachel
um so I'm here with an amazing panel of
people who bring just a real variety of
perspectives to this topic
um of incarceration and Imagination in
um in a multi-genre way Rachel Kushner
who is sitting to my right is a novelist
um her novels are Telex from Cuba the
flamethrowers the Mars room I have read
these books with great pleasure and
partly agreed to participate in the
stakes I was so excited to meet Rachel
um I really recommend them and she has a
book of essays called the hard crowd and
is a contributor to the New Yorker the
New York Times magazine and a columnist
for Harpers
Caleb Smith is a professor of English
and American studies at Yale and his
books that are especially relevant to
today's discussion are the prison and
the American imagination and an addition
of Austin Reed's life of The Adventures
of a haunted convict
and Joy James who is further to my right
is
um the Ebenezer Fitch professor of
humanities at Williams college and the
editor of four anthologies about
political prisoners and political
activists
um so I'm delighted to be here um with
this fabulous group and as you can tell
we're spanning a number of genres here
um this is a group that represents
fiction thinking about
um the prison as a space in which to
create fiction that is obviously like a
choice that Rachel made in her third
book
um a choice about setting
um that I'm really eager to hear more
about
um and Caleb has written non-fiction and
then thought a lot about first-person
accounts and narratives
um from people who are incarcerated
which he will talk about more and joy
has this perspective of people who are
activists both within and outside of
prison
um and will be the respondent on the
panel so
um Rachel I was hoping that you would
talk a little bit about what you think
fiction is doing in this um space of
incarceration is it about witnessing and
if so how does it differ what can an
offer that's different from non-fiction
or kind of first-person accounts of life
in prison which are of course really
important and we have people in this
room today who have those perspectives
to offer and I'm really interested in
how you think the genre of fiction can
complement some of the other writing and
work and art we have in this area so can
I turn that over to you with that
question
yeah
um should we share this I don't know
sure you can use it first all right
like a math problem we have four people
and three microphones
um each person gets a microphone for
1.33 of the time
um well
I wrote a little paper should I just
read my paper or should I answer that
question well you could read your paper
and hopefully the answers will emerge at
some point yeah you have a while so it's
I think that um I think that
um what I brought to present to you all
here today very much speaks to
um exactly the points that you just
brought up so should I just go for it
yes okay
okay it's 9 20.
I think these are supposed to be like 10
to 12 minutes correct all right
when I was working on my novel The Mars
room I asked a friend who had spent 23
years in the prison on which I modeled
my fictional one if women on death row
there worked jobs they worked she said
they have six sewing machines
what do they so I asked sandbags she
said for the California Department of
Transportation hearing this an image
flashed into my thoughts of an
industrial axle turning and turning as
if I had suddenly been exposed to The
Boiler Room of the world or rather of
California which might as well be the
world with its 40 million
after that conversation every time I saw
a sandbag on the side of the highway I
felt the turn of this axle and I
pictured women running synthetic fabric
along the presser foot of a
state-supplied sewing machine
these sandbags which are everywhere when
you start to look remain for me a potent
symbol that the penal system is floating
all over the place
after I wrote the Mars room there was a
question people sometimes asked that I
did not like why didn't you write a
non-fiction book about this I responded
mostly by asking in turn is not the
novel a parallel universe where we can
Glimpse and understand aspects of this
one
I think it's no accident that this
Symposium was conceived by someone who
has given so much thought to the work of
Balzac that's Peter Brooks Balzac's
novels stand as a kind of zenith of what
the 19th century novel can do namely
report on social reality in both its
fine-grained detail and in its sweep and
structures Marx and Engels famously
turned to Balzac for what his novels
revealed about Capital entire chapters
of Thomas piketty's capital in the 21st
century rely on bozock novels for their
illumination of wealth distribution as
Peter Brooks notes balzog strove to
rival the Civil registry in his
determination to people his world so
thoroughly from Bankers to peasants to
poets to the figure of course of the
criminal male whose cunning is to find
shortcuts to wealth women might be
tragic but only men like balzok's
Infamous anti-hero Votran can transgress
the shadow of the criminal in literature
and also movies is long it stretches
from the 19th century into the mid-20th
with figures like Andy Griffith's
character in a face in the crowd
discovered in the local jail who Rises
to demonic Heights as a Donald
trump-like Peddler of serums Cool Hand
Luke's failure to communicate with a
Florida prison Warden and Norman
mailer's version of Gary Gilmore in The
Executioner's Song by 1981 when
imprisoned writer Jack Henry Abbott's
letters to Norman Miller were published
as the book in the belly of the Beast
this Shadow was I would argue overtaken
by a more engulfing set of Shadows the
ones cast by institutions the punitive
turn in the parlance of our Symposium
prompt
the reformatories and prisons that had
shaped Jack Henry Abbott left such a
mark on him that he was free only six
weeks before he stabbed and killed
someone six weeks after that tragic turn
of events Michiko kakutani then the most
powerful literary critic in America
condemned Norman Mailer in a New York
Times article titled The Strange Case of
the writer and the criminal
kakutani summarized Jack Henry Abbott's
long incarceration and short brutal
Freedom she blamed Norman mailer for the
stabbing of the victim a young actor
named Richard Auden she talked about
mailer's obsession with violence and
suggested that writers can only ever
play with violence and that such play
brings consequences
kakutani's argument relies on the idea
that the criminal is a social type a
member if you will of Balzac's registry
she's unaware and unwilling to grasp
what prison even already by 1981 had
become in America a way to manage social
problems and inequality
prisons draw as we all know from only
one layer of society fate of origin and
not just Destiny do inform character in
life and in novels but kakutani suggests
that Jack Henry Abbott's problem is that
he isn't a reasonable man that's the
term she uses her article is fascinating
to me because it is such a transparent
attempt to exhaustively close a chapter
of American literary history one in
which as she sees it writers believe
there is a moral symbolism in crime and
punishment
but it is kakutani's argument itself
that is wouldn't it be funny if she was
here today
but it is kakutani's argument itself
that is foreclosed and moribund by 1981
the United States has embarked on a
prison building project of breathtaking
scope and reach by then literary meaning
lies not in the figure of the so-called
criminal but in the institutions that
shape this person to say something true
about a modern day votron the novelist
must perceive and understand the
institutions that overshadow him
an interesting echo of Balzac's ambition
to rival the Civil registry can be found
in Michel Foucault's hope to rival a
registry of internment dating from the
18th century that he came upon in the
bibliotech Nacional
Foucault planned to write a book
inspired by the brief descriptions of
imprisoned people in this registry his
book would be titled the life of
Infamous Men He described the feeling he
got upon reading brief and fragmented
accounts of people whose stories
suddenly rose up for him through two and
a half centuries of Silence what
Foucault aimed to do was to restore the
intensity of these obscure and unknown
people's lives lives as he put it
reduced to ashes in the Curt tone of a
public Ledger book
Foucault describes them as cobblers
deserting soldiers Vagabond monks all
these people might have stayed in the
dark he says were it not for the light
of power that Shone down on them their
moment in court in prison in this
registry he holds in his hands
to write about a prison is perhaps not
unlike writing about a school the
culture of a sea vessel a hospital or
any other self-enclosed world in this
sense I see a thread connecting
Melville's Moby Dick to keezy's One Flew
Over the Cuckoo's Nest and John
cheever's falconer but much of what
sustains a prison happens outside a
prison the penal system as I said is
floating everywhere seen or unseen
depending the writer may have been
ensnared in it and recount from personal
experience as many have I never was but
I grew up with people who were kids
whose fathers happen to be police
officers while these kids all had a
parole officer their mothers worked at
Bail Bonds companies or as court clerks
downtown
now I live in Los Angeles the nation's
most populous County my home is walking
distance from our Criminal Court complex
a mile to the east is our jail complex
what I write as fiction cannot keep out
what I see I cannot help but notice who
goes to court to jail and who works in
these places this is the world in which
Balzac's Votran now finds himself Los
Angeles
manufacturing capital of the U.S and a
place of extreme wealth inequality a
city that spends half of its operating
budget on police
the trans job prospects might be a
sorting Warehouse in the Inland Empire
or something higher paying and less
legal he might be the descendant of
people who came West from Texas and
Louisiana to work unskilled jobs in the
Aerospace industry jobs that have long
vanished this new Votran is possibly
acquainted with foster care Youth
Authority and family court he might try
to find a shortcut to wealth or more
modestly survival but in a modern novel
he is not counseling Balzac's rostenyak
on marrying Rich ladies he is boarding a
sheriff's department bus along with 60
other men and heading for Corker in
prison deep in the heart of industrial
Farmland where 6 000 others stand around
on level 4 housing yards overseen by
guards for whom prisons are one of the
biggest Employers in their rural County
Corcoran is surrounded by irrigation
canals through which subsidized water
flows water used to grow almonds that
are exported all over the world a crop
that is largely automated and thus jobs
in prisons rather than farming
in order to understand the life of this
Votran the author of the novel who casts
him in a role will want to have some
sense of cycles of drought and economic
recession and state capacity she'll want
to know how hot it is on a level 4 yard
at Salinas Valley or Chowchilla or Chino
she'll want to have Glimpse the circular
logic of California prison Industries
where they make pews for juries who
decide the fate of people like them
about her votron the novelist will want
to have a sense of the racial and class
barriers he has faced and of how and why
her character might decide
catastrophically and probably quickly
that violence could be a solution to his
problems
this is a modern Voltron in modern
California he has come a long way from a
Balzac novel and he might even be a
woman which is how I wrote her in my
attempt to depict in my novel The Mars
room the life of someone put on a bus to
prison in the Central Valley
I want to close by coming back to this
question people have asked me why not
write a non-fiction book about this
stuff
the question isn't really a question
it's a suggestion that one should be
doing activism or at the very least
journalism instead of writing novels if
you're going to bother people with such
quote unquote unpleasantness
Foucault's proposed project of
converting the internment registry into
narratives anticipated this very
reaction it is in the infamous of his
title lives of Infamous men an adjective
adding a promise of the lurid and The
Sensational which I interpret as irony
the real life Outlaw even now 300 years
ago was already buried under the shadow
of the bureaucracies meant to limit and
control him to manage him
of the project to restore this man's
intensity as Foucault put it
Foucault himself said he lacked the
necessary Talent he never wrote the book
I regard this Phantom project he
proposed as explicitly for us the
novelists if not to complete to at least
begin
thank you
[Applause]
um Caleb you were going to talk about I
think a different kind of writing from
within prisons
um conversion narratives uh so I will
turn things over to you
thank you Emily Rachel Joy everyone who
did the work to organize this conference
um when I saw the the title for our
panel literary history of the
incarcerated mind that singular really
stood out to me the mind
and since Peter mentioned some kind of
inspiration for this conference coming
out of
his prison teaching um also an uh one of
my own experiences with prison teaching
um
sure
is that better can you hear me so one of
my own experiences with prison teaching
has been kind of lingering in my
Consciousness as I prepared for this
event and it was a conversation I had
with a student named Clyde when I was
teaching in Cheshire correctional
institute with the wesleyan's prison
program before we had our own here at
Yale
and um we were discussing uh Frederick
douglass's
1845 narrative in that class and and
Clyde was who was kind of a leader is
Clyde here he's here at Yale as a
um as a fellow now that
um
sort of interrupted the conversation and
he said you know he'd been taking
Wesleyan classes for years at this point
he said you know
people like you come in here they want
us to read Douglas and they want us to
read Foucault and they want to ask me
about my subjectivity
he said what I want to know is what
about your subjectivity
and that resistance to
um being seen as someone whose
subjectivity was an object of curiosity
and an object of interest on the people
who are coming in even presumably to be
his teachers as something that I have
really tried to think about the sources
of and dwell with a little bit when I
wanted to talk today about a specific
genre that seems to me very Central to
the long literary history of imagining
and attempting to understand or give
accounts of incarcerated minds and that
is the conversion narrative
specifically the Protestant religious
conversion narrative
um and some of my research on the early
decades uh and the cultural history of
the U.S prison system in the 18 teens
20s 30s and 40s I recently came across
this very remarkable grave in
Canandaigua New York
um it's a big Monument with a tall
Obelisk above it and a weathered metal
plate inscribed on it and the text of
the inscription reads this way
Jacob Hodges an African negro
born in poverty and ignorance early
tempted to sin by designing and wicked
men
once condemned as a felon
converted by the grace of God in prison
lived many years a converted and useful
Christian
died February 1842 in the faith of the
Gospel about 80 years of age
this Monument identifies the man by his
name and by his race
and then it tells very briefly the story
of his life it goes back to his
childhood in poverty and ignorance
passes through the crisis of his
temptation and his sin Hodges as it
turned out was kind of conscripted by
conspirators to participate in the
murder of a white property holder in
Orange County New York
it recounts his religious experience in
prison
and it confirms the lasting effects of
that religious experience when he was
converted by the grace of God in prison
this grave marker says the change in his
character wasn't just a fleeting kind of
affectation it really turned him around
for good and he lived many years this
way in the faith of the Gospel so these
are the kind of elements of a Protestant
conversion narrative
uh first his ignorance then his
seduction then his sin then judgment and
suffering conversion and this new more
faithful life that he lives out for the
rest of his days
above that
um congregationalist or anglo-protestant
uh conversion narrative there's this
Egyptian symbol obelisk
um and I learned a little bit about this
trying to understand it and and learn
that by the by about 1842 there were a
number of obelisks in the North Atlantic
metropols and it would be just six years
later that construction began on the
most famous one in the United States the
Washington Monument
um so in 1842 in an Upstate New York
village Cemetery this is not exactly a
shocking image but it's a sort of it is
a symbol of a kind of appropriation of
an African form into this anglo-american
settler civilization the place is called
Pioneer Cemetery
um
so it so it seems uh plausible to me
that this particular symbol was chosen
partly because as a kind of Testament to
the successful racial assimilation of
Jacob Hodges into this Upstate Community
by way of his religious conversion or at
least to the hope of a kind of racial
assimilation in a post-emancipation era
in New York state
and then finally there's the metal plate
itself
um I mean obelisks are ancient
Protestant conversion narratives go back
at least to early New England
settlements on this continent
but that metal plate is forged in a
Foundry and it has forged bolts that are
securing it into the the base of this
tomb
and so in that way it's not only an
ancient or even an old-fashioned
Christian form but also this tomb is
very much an artifact of the new
industrial economy that was taking shape
in Upstate New York and
one of whose major
sites of development was the contract
operated workshops of Auburn State
Prison where Jacob Hodges was
incarcerated for most of a decade
so I take this
um
grave to be telling one person's story
by way of the conversion narrative
but also as a kind of artifact of
these three forces that came together at
the foundational moment of modern
industrial prison discipline
and those are
Evangelical religion
a
conflicts and struggles over the
question of post-dimension emancipation
racial assimilation
um so at this is the time of arguments
about
colonization versus education efforts to
lift up the states growing free black
population upstate New York
and also the industrial economy that was
very quickly transforming the economy of
Upstate New York with the what's
historians sometimes called the market
Revolution and industrialization which
involved a rapid transition away from
older systems not only of slavery but
also of indenture and apprenticeship
toward wage labor so that the laboring
population was suddenly much more mobile
and each worker much more on their own
and many
instances of discipline that previously
would have been handled domestically
that is by Masters are now being
outsourced to the state which is doing
them in this doing prison doing labor
discipline and moral discipline in the
new institutions
you can see I think
um why a conversion narrative would be
useful to a prison system that explained
its project in terms of Rehabilitation
um it was aligned with the reformist
program not with vengeance and not even
with mere incapacitation but with the
promise that people's characters could
be rehabilitated in prisons
it was
um also aligned specifically with
religious liberty The chaplains Who
operated in Auburn State Prison
were not paid by the state they were
paid by philanthropic organizations and
so you're
um your religious education in a place
like Auburn could be seen as voluntary
not State imposed
um and we have much Evangelical activism
to this day which understands itself to
be in favor of Rehabilitation but not in
favor of Rehabilitation under the
direction of state-appointed Elites
um
so those are the uh and you can also see
I think the kind of ideological work
that a prison prison conversion
narratives would have done in the 19th
century and perhaps still do today
they give a kind of moral legitimacy to
large-scale captivity and compulsory
discipline
um and uh specifically tend to
align the a line incarceration not with
re-enslavement not with violence but
instead with a kind of moral correction
but over the past 200 years as you can
probably imagine the conversion
narrative as a kind of template for
telling someone's life story or telling
the story of someone's experience in
prison going through suffering has also
been adapted to many other uses
uh for
um
criminal justice reformers the ideal of
Rehabilitation and in some cases the
ideal of a kind of conversion or
transformation of one's character
is often held up as the ideal
against which other more abusive
realities and injustices can be measured
so it has can have this kind of critical
function into the in relation to the way
that criminal justice is actually being
enforced
it also has been taken up in more
militant and radical ways
you can think about
um
autobiographies and even shorter pieces
of
autobiographical prison writing that
talk about the author's conversion not
to a kind of the docility of a Christian
conversion and acceptance of the justice
of their own sentence but instead to
kind of militant opposition to the
systems that have that have seized them
right we can think about conversions to
Marxism conversions to radical Islam
conversions to faiths and and positions
that happened through the prison
experience but that set set the author
now against the system that has
condemned them
for
people like me who work in literary
studies and cultural studies these
documents have a real richness
they are available to humanist kinds of
reading and criticism
we may have a sense in reading them that
we've been able to recover or at least
acknowledge voices against the silencing
power of the state
we might encounter real
um
narratives of psychological and
spiritual vividness in these personal
accounts the traditional the kind of
irony of the traditional conversion
narratives that it was supposed to be
your own intensely sincere experience
but it wasn't a real conversion
narrative unless it conformed perfectly
to the template of the of the conversion
narrative right
um but but people have but of course
developed stories about conversion that
have a lot of idiosyncrasy and richness
and intensity and singularity
we can read these texts for moments in
which they
seem to resist or subvert
or even just improvise against what
seems to be the script that's been
provided for them to perform and so
locate moments
of agency locate moments of subversion
so on
it is a genre that has a long history
then and many uses and much risk
richness
at the same time it has its uh limits or
certain ways of approaching it can be
limiting
and specifically
um one reason I'm glad to be thinking
here with Rachel's account of what
novels can do is that much of what she's
just described in terms of the sweep of
a social world is what Falls away in a
conversion narrative
the incarcerated mind right
um the conversion narrative itself
may be part of its ideological function
is to say hey the prison isn't so bad it
actually gave me this opportunity to
correct myself and rehabilitate myself
and so on but another part of its
ideological function is to say
here is one story
one person's story and that's what
prison is it's one person's story right
so the large
sweep and scale
of the catastrophe may drop out of view
if we think about the singularity of
this voice
how then do we scale up
from this one story to the mass to the
system to the structure
I think this is a problem in how we
think about conversion narratives and in
some ways I think it's a problem at the
heart of how much the humanities
themselves can say or do in relation to
these systems
um
but what I've tried to at least sketch
out here at least at the beginning
there's ways of reading these not only
in order to acknowledge and value the
particular stories that they tell but
also to move out from them into the
scales and structures of historical
forces that give them weight and give
them meaning
and the three in particular that seem
resonant to me that seem almost to have
um
come out of frozenness and reanimated
themselves in our own time are the three
that I mentioned shaping the tomb of
Jacob Hodges at the beginning
we have a very active Evangelical white
Evangelical movement aligned with the
politics of harsh punishment in our
country right now just as they did in
the burned over District of Upstate New
York during the Great Awakening of the
1840s
we have radical shift and
destabilization of our economic system
for them it was the transition from
indenture apprenticeship and slavery
toward industrialism and wage labor
for us it is the other side of
de-industrialization that's been
analyzed by Ruthie Wilson Gilmore and
many others as being the economic
context within which the system takes
shape
and we have a kind of moral Panic about
racialized migrant laboring populations
just as they did in Upstate New York in
the 1840s on conflicts over whether
there will be a kind of assimilation
overseen
by white Christian nationalist
authorities or whether there can only be
exclusion separation and expulsion and
reading for those
political forces is one way I think we
can both see the singularity of the
conversion narrative and of the voice in
it and also think about some of the
larger political and cultural forces
that give it its force and give it its
meaning and toward which we have to gain
some leverage thanks
um thank you
can I hand it over to you yeah sure
great okay good morning
um thank you
excuse me thank you Rachel and Caleb
it's really rich so I've got five
minutes okay I'm gonna have to squash
um
there's a lot in in both of your you
know contributions and I started
thinking
excuse me I started thinking of
dichotomies
and the possibility of what could be
synthesized right so you have fiction
you have non-fiction you have this
subject gazing at the object meaning the
incarcerated
I also wanted to add the possibility
that there's the focus on the individual
but there's also the collective in the
communal right that whole communities
can be decimated and they reconstituted
that fathers will meet their sons
incarcerated you know mothers who have
long terms can meet their children or we
spoke about it last night give birth
inside of these systems and then have
their child removed and disappeared
right
so I'm wondering how you see the
convergence right as a conversion
narrative right so I mean Caleb you laid
out
what we've inherited and what we will
leave our children
um hopefully it will improve but you
know the odds didn't seems so great at
the moment so Kathy Bulow who's at
University of Chicago has a text on how
the white supremacist underground came
above ground and these long Wars that
the U.S had in the Middle East actually
professionalize them as an army right
and so it's not just what happens in the
voting space it's also what happens with
people who I think you were pointing to
when you're talking about this
increasing animus against
um migration right from sites that have
been devastated by the over consumption
right of water and and you know
environment Devastation might done
largely by the West so if there is a
convergence
what might that look like as a political
phenomena
and also what are the possibilities that
as much as we emphasize morality
we need a shared understanding of
political ethics
right so how we want to be as moral
people is that we care about the
incarcerated which is you know and I
really heard you when you said well you
know people are saying well why why
don't you do non-fiction and be useful
right which of course is a false
dichotomy because your work is
abolitionist work and people who are
incarcerated at least a few times I've
been able to be inside they are also
writers and authors and they read novels
and they write novels they write poetry
they write Memoirs but I'm wondering you
know as academics and people in this
room are also writers to what extent do
we have a community of writers whatever
genre we explore or you know dabble in
or become professionalized in or
brilliant in
that it actually constitutes a political
ethics that can bring another kind of
conversion narrative other than the
Evangelical reactionaries that are on
the rise and I'm not sure
like that we've agreed to even attempt
that endeavor
like these are all peers the
incarcerated writers are our peers right
and our teachers
and I wonder what what would it take
um you know to push forward with that
and I just want to give a couple like
specifics because I know I like I have
two minutes left
um
so I was thinking of you know you you
brought up Foucault and Foucault visited
Attica
and Foucault also under the
encouragement of Jean Janae wrote a
pamphlet that gilamart
um published it was in French to like a
decade or so ago I think it was called
the assassination of the mass
assassination and he was talking about
George Jackson's death so this would be
someone who needed a conversion but it
wasn't going to be into a certain kind
of religiosity it was in it was going to
be a conversion to a certain kind of
militancy aligned with the Black Panther
Party and I would argue that the state
and Society doesn't want those kind of
conversions
so
if we
I don't you know I can't I mean I've got
60 seconds now so but I'm really
troubled by the ethics of this
like what we don't want
is what will continue to manifest
because of the violence arrayed against
certain communities
so do we have a tolerance of interacting
with what we don't want right to stitch
together a sort of common political
ethics so Jean Janae wrote the forward
to George Jackson's book at the
encouragement of Faith Center who is
attorney you know kind of recruited him
you know his white intellectuals I want
you to do you know I'm my legal degree
is from University of Chicago
I want you to do this for this book
that's very rebellious and he agreed to
do that right James Baldwin will write
an open letter for Angela Davis when
she's on trial and before increasingly
the populations can say we can Embrace
here we understand that she has a
certain kind of innocent and legitimacy
but there are people who are Rebels and
they're people who are not innocent and
they continue as their peers so
if we were to recognize that what would
we become
and then how does that you know subject
object
you know dichotomy become a synthesis in
the fiction non-fiction can emerge into
just like literary contributions that
would allow us to have more strategies
and more tools for what we need to do
um I love that thank you
um I'm gonna add a little bit to this
um discussion because it's uh hitting so
many notes from my own work um so I
can't quite resist uh
Caleb you were talking about the
American mind and I think in or I'm
sorry the incarcerated mind could also
be the American mind and I always
pluralize words like that because to me
as a journalist one of the most
um difficult aspects of my work is
figuring out how to use a story a
narrative to say something about this
scaled up catastrophe
um and you know Joy you're taking this
in a another Direction
um not just multiplicity but thinking of
people as peers as opposed to
necessarily the subject object
relationship
um and when you're a writer who's not
yourself incarcerated and you're writing
other about other people there is this
kind of way in which they are if not the
object in uh you know abstract way
um you're trying to understand their
world you're not within it
um and I think the reason to me that's
so obvious for art or novels or fiction
or movies about um incarcerated people
and environments in the communities
they're part of is that hopefully those
are things that move people or outside
this self-enclosed world that you were
talking about Rachel and so there's a
parallel universe that pulls in more
people's hearts and Minds
um but the step to thinking about people
as peers is a more radical and profound
step that I think you know as a society
we have
um we continue to fail at almost all the
time I've been thinking about it
personally because I wrote a story for
the New York Times magazine a couple
years ago or actually a year and a half
ago about uh um a man named judico
Briley who wrote To Me from prison and
um he wrote a short but very clear
letter I get a lot of mail from
incarcerated people lots of lawyers and
journalists and even professors
um do and it's hard to know what to make
of this multiplicity of voices it can
feel sort of overwhelming but this led
touched me for a couple of reasons there
was a claim of Innocence that Utica made
in it but he also said that he was in
prison for 60 years for an armed robbery
and nobody had been injured in that
armed robbery and so my initial response
was to think well that was so
drastically unfair such an example of
excessive punishment which is something
Dwayne betz who unfortunately isn't here
with us today but something he talks and
thinks and has taught me a lot about so
I reached out to Utica we started
corresponding
um through JPay the sort of corrupt uh
for-profit service that is what a lot of
incarcerated people are forced to rely
on and Utica was sort of having to reel
me in right and interest me there was
this way in which
um he stood to he he had to figure out a
way to persuade me to care about him and
then over the course of time I got more
involved in this case I ended up looking
for a lawyer for him because it was so
clear to me that what he needed was a
lawyer not a journalist at this moment
um that lawyer happened to me my sister
so then this trying to figure out you
know whether there was a way to
exonerate you to Utica years after he'd
been incarcerated became this kind of
joint project and utico is a very
charismatic person so his sort of
personhood was really important to what
we were working on and he was really in
a lot of ways I he was driving what was
happening but also of course had kind of
limited agency necessarily
um so in the end he he was not guilty of
this crime he'd been convicted of and he
was exonerated in part because the
community in New Orleans changed the
voters
um decide to elect a new district
attorney and a new judge who were much
more interested in actual Justice than
the people who'd preceded them and so
um Utica was uh got out of prison was
exonerated it's now about a year and a
half later and I started getting more
mail after my piece came out not
surprisingly and I couldn't bear to just
not respond to the letters in the way
that I had tended to do in the past so I
started a project here at Yale in which
law students and I have been working
with these letters to create a database
that's on the freedom reads website and
is trying to amplify the voices of
incarcerated people and it's very much
about a kind of multiplicity of voices
and hoping that this is something Dwayne
says a lot that if people could see and
hear the voices that we see in here if
you're in touch with people on the
inside that maybe that would create the
kind of energy for Change and radical
reform that we are still lacking it's
not quite a pure relationship though
um and yet I have ended up having
exactly that relationship with um
someone who's incarcerated whose name is
John J Lennon who's a prison journalist
who Dwayne introduced me to and John and
I have been writing together a
newsletter for the New York Times about
some of these stories that are coming in
and it's really turned into a
collaboration I don't think I really
thought it through very much when Dwayne
proposed it I was sort of glad to feel
like maybe I was supporting John in some
way but that is not the way the
relationship is developed John turns out
to have
um lots of ideas to offer but also
incredible patience so we had this
period over the summer where my editors
were not not really sure what shape they
wanted the first edition of this
newsletter to take and I was getting
really impatient with them and
frustrated
and John was the one who really kind of
saw through my frustration and was able
to say you know what like they are
trying to make this as good as it can be
and we need to take their feedback and
um and really incorporate it and think
about you know why they're having us
change course and he was by far the more
mature one in this interaction of the
two of us which shouldn't have really
surprised me and yet it really turned
the tables on my own assumptions about
um who peers can be and what those kinds
of relationships can be so I I guess I'm
telling the story because
um it seems to me that what we're
hearing up here is this sort of
grappling with what it is to tell
stories to figure out a way how to scale
them up to recognition of the
catastrophe or talking about Caleb but
then also figuring out this move where
we're not just sort of bestowing
attention we're also really seeing
people as individual humans and as just
like us just in a different
self-enclosed world
um so that was a little bit of a lot of
uh thinking but I wonder
um Rachel if that speaks to some of your
work well
yeah I'm I'm still thinking about
um
what Joy was saying like so many uh
incredibly incisive points she made that
I immediately wanted to respond to and
then incorporate what you just said
Emily but so back to Jean Janae just for
a quick second I'm so glad you mentioned
him because actually in that
incredibly damning article self-damming
maybe a piece that kakutani wrote in
1981. she quotes Joyce Carol Oates who
says that actually Jack Henry Abbott was
not a real criminal or an authentic
criminal and she uses the word authentic
because he seemed like somebody who'd
read a lot of Jean Janae and so she's
desperate to keep writers over here and
criminals over here and anybody who
smells like literature cannot come from
the streets and it's just um it's
wonderfully transparent or horribly
transparent in my own
experiences working with people inside
prison which I do separate from writing
novels
um I have peers who are serving life
sentences in one case somebody who's
serving two life sentences meaning when
she goes up for parole after her 25
years
um if the parole board deems her
suitable for Freedom then she can start
her second sentence
um and a lot of these people are readers
I have one friend in prison who told me
that the most popular book on
administrative segregation which is
chowchilla's version of solitary
um the most popular book is malice by
Danielle Steel and I said that's a novel
about women in prison she goes yeah
and I've quite ignorantly this was
several years ago said and I'm
embarrassed to admit this but I think
it's useful I said why would you want to
read your you guys are stuck in prison
why would you want to read a novel about
prison and she goes Rach we don't just
want to read novels about your guys's
you're all's divorce or whatever she's
like we want to read books about people
like us
um and what she was doing was
challenging me but also supporting me
because I wanted to write this novel The
Mars room and she was like you do that
you write that novel
um
I also you know I work with people in
prison together on projects um I used to
be involved with this organization
Justice now whose board of directors was
comprised entirely of people inside
prison mostly serving very long
sentences and the reason that was the
case was because the woman who started
that organization actually got the phase
tender award one year
um said to a friend of hers inside
prison bring me like shock collars bring
me the most influential people in the
whole prison and those are people who
are serving very long sentences and then
they were trained in human rights work
to like Each one teach one and teach the
you know the signs of Human Rights
abuses to other people in prison
working with those people I am much more
a student than I am a teacher and I
don't fool myself that this is an uh
Equitable world that I'm acutely aware
of these power differentials they can
call me collect I can simply not answer
the phone
um I cannot call them
Etc I think that this work is uneven and
ongoing to answer that in terms of maybe
I misunderstand but you brought up
morality and I thought this is such an
interesting word to use in a world where
the religion and ideology of liberalism
is that liberalism as a kind of
universalism is going to hold up any
person who wants it and then can access
the kind of Freedom that liberalism
affords us like consumer Freedom this is
not the case so then what do we do with
if I understand it individual morality
as opposed to a collective ethics
um the last thing I just want to say
quickly is listening to Caleb's talk I
was reminded of what seems to me a
really terrible irony at least in
California which is that maybe the only
vestiges left of the idea of a
fundamentalist conversion narrative in
the prisons that are managed by the
California Department of Corrections is
that the Bible is the one thing you can
have no matter what you've done in
prison when you find yourself in the
jail of the prison or the jail of the
jail of the prison which would be to go
to solitary and leave your prison that
ad sag and go to an ad seg ad seg prison
they will never take away your Bible and
it's almost as if they are saying and I
only realize this listening to him talk
that those inside prison who have messed
up are condemned to religion in a way
that the rest of us are not we can
continue to shop and Lease cars and do
this and that but they have to pray
what you're describing is
um the ongoing
um it's quite exactly continuous with uh
Evangelical prison reform in the 1820s
whose project was to mass print Bibles
and put one in every single cell I mean
Jacob Hodges was released one of the
reformers went and asked him if he could
have the prison Bible that had converted
that Hodges had had his conversion with
I was like no you can't have it why
would you presume that you can take this
away from you know one this one thing
and after he died Hodges sent it to the
reform Society in this Minister Louis
Dwight used to go around holding up
Hodges Bible as the kind of prop in his
sermons it's an interesting thing
because evangelicalism what it was like
a first mass media religious movement
just as it has become like a television
televangelism and internet phenomenon
now but suddenly the mass printing gave
like regressed back to this fetish of
the single the single object that had
converted Hodges
yeah the aura comes back yeah um I want
to say a little bit about to uh Joy's
great question about what forms of
Community are
um kind of broken apart and
reconstituted
as sometimes when we describe
um criminalization and incarceration as
a tactic of class war and race war the
response of that is oh but a lot of poor
people support harsh punishment or a lot
of people in the black community support
want the police to keep them safe or
something and the point is not
people with
privilege and property support harsh
punishment and everyone else doesn't
it's that criminalization and
incarceration and policing as the only
point of interface with any kind of
state service divides right
creates this Division and um in New York
state already in the 1840s the stone
cutting Masons at large were saying we
can't compete with this incarcerated
labor that's no wage labor and it's
creating a class division within this
emergent working class in the era of
wage labor and that is ongoing but but
it's also true that we see I mean I
think your point about some conversions
are isolating and some are conversions
into a different solidarity or into a
different Community is really a
meaningful one that I didn't draw out
much in my presentation
um you know often those of us who teach
learn from our students that they've
been going off to the block and and
conducting seminars on the same topics
not that they're transmitting what I
said about the text but that they're
having their own discussion about the
text and some of that is coming back to
change our conversation in the room
um
the uh the kinds of
um the kinds of small scale scale
connections and community that get
formed on those long bus rides you know
out to the Central Valley or something
and then then become networks of
activism that can link out and so on
um I think I and I really like the
distinction between a kind of moralism
and an ethics for my part I do become a
little wary when I hear a language of we
need a reckoning on this topic
um as if a kind you know as if the
spirit is going to sweep across the land
and people are going to embrace a new
faith on Justice
um to me that is that kind of talk is
um
is Expresses in part A sense of
um dispossession and no access to the
real mechanisms of how you change a
political structure
um and so the idea of an ethic that's
more about well people might actually
have many reasons for being against this
or for being in solidarity with each
other and that there would be a kind of
lateral ethic of mutual respect of what
brings people to the work around a
common project is the way that I
um
that I would understand that difference
between a kind of you know um an
Awakening and a
kind of solidarity ethic you know this
um
well I think yeah I think that's what
that's I want to give other people some
time to talk soon yeah so is this a half
joke for racial as a former seminarian
it's praying it works but
um also I think it's interesting we've
talked a lot about Christianity it's a
number of people that I know who like so
my work right is political Theory and I
work with radical you know theorists but
people who were in the Panthers are now
um Muslims so their names are changed
so there is something about spirituality
and religion and maybe because it is
Islam that is it's also a key honor to
you know a reactionary Christian state
or certain kind of
um
dictate like you're saying the Bible is
sacred you could you know that's your
key you could carry it anywhere Quran
maybe no if you're a Buddhist you know
maybe you have a little gray area
um I'm wondering to go back to something
I asked before and I also want to put on
the table
there's a prison strike right now in
Alabama
right and so we talk a lot about
censorship around critical race Theory
like the banned books thing that appears
to be mushrooming you know from the
south and then moving
um across the U.S I'm wondering if you
have any thoughts about
how incarcerated writers are censored
and how it's difficult for them to get
their works out particularly if they're
critical of this of the state itself
because we've never
we know that the state has predatory
strategies and a history the 13th
Amendment legalizes enslavement right in
prisons
or if you've been duly convicted of a
crime so that's kind of on the table and
then the last thing that I'll stop is
the dichotomy between the privileged
imprisoned or prisoner and then the one
that is Expendable so when Davis was on
trial she had a co-defendant Rochelle
McGee and there was an online
celebration of his 82nd birthday he's
still inside right because he didn't he
you know one he actually was in Marin
County and he was holding one of her
guns right
but his argument is that he was a slave
and all slaves have the right to
fugitivity
Davis's position was that she is not a
slave she's a citizen and so she has the
right to the protection of law there are
segments of the incarcerated
who
see themselves as captive
through the filter the 13th Amendment
and so their writings will be less
likely to appear in public and so the
Public's ability to protect them
if you know like Stevie Wilson who's a
black queer writer he gets he's
continuously thrown in the hole because
he's talking about abuses by guards
abuses by systems right so I'm wondering
about you know the protective mechanism
that the author can offer
to the incarcerated
I mean we could just I wish you know we
don't have that much time in there you
just raise many important points but
just a couple things that come to mind
um
sorry to sound acerbic but The Marshall
Project is an organization that was
started by Bill Keller who used to be
that was the editor of the New York
Times and it's meant to be a project
um about incarceration in America and
when it was first started they had a
kind of like fundraising cocktail party
in Los Angeles and somebody invited me
even though I was not the target
audience of the party which was about
raising money and I asked are you going
to uh have a section where you share the
writing of incarcerated people and Bill
Keller said well this is not going to be
prison poetry monthly and people went
and I you know wanted to gun down the
entire crowd but um so then The Marshall
Project started and I did turn to it as
a resource for friends inside prison who
wanted an outlet for their riding
because of what they were doing and they
had a really you know big platform and a
lot of money behind it and um one friend
of mine's work was published in The
Marshall Project twice and I had to be
horror interlocutor with them because
they didn't have a JPay thing set up at
the time and so she would send the
pieces to me and I would send them to
them and I noticed that she was always
calling the editor mister and I would
have these conversations with her don't
call him Mister you know he's merely
your editor this is he's not a guard he
is not your counselor in prison but it
was just so hard for her to get Beyond
these kinds of institutional hierarchies
sorts of
um exchanges anyone free is like a
mister or a Mrs so when her piece her
first piece was published for the
biography the editor asked me can you
supply a bar no he didn't ask me if you
can use Supply biography he he didn't
say anything about the bio and I said
you do you need a bio for this writer
and he said oh for the incarcerated
writer's wheat
we Inc we include their age the prison
where they're incarcerated and the crime
of which they were convicted
and I I honestly saw a man opening a
woman's mouth to count her teeth
and I started just totally freaked out
and said you can't you know but then I'm
in this position do I want to stop my
friend from being published in this
magazine or do I have to Ascent to their
rules and I got into a big fight with
The Marshall Project that is ongoing to
this day but for that one thing he said
I just won't include a bio
so she didn't get to be treated with the
normal courtesy with which a writer was
treated and at first I tried to use kind
of obfuscation and say oh women don't
like to have their age mentioned in
their bio that's not the normal kind of
thing you would put I mean it was like
birth date
location and crime
so there are these Outlets that were
given as resources to help our friends
inside prison but we have to push back
against these idea that they would be
otherwise at every step of the way I
don't know if that speaks to some of
what you're saying but that's what came
to mind I just have a short update
because I was talking with John Lennon
about this very issue recently he's been
he has been a contributor to The
Marshall Project and your advocacy I
think had some effect Rachel
um although I think he and other people
have continued it so he wound up as an
advisor to what is I think and I don't
work at The Marshall Project so if other
people have other information maybe we
can add that during the questions but he
became an advisor what I think has
become a sort of regular contributor
feature part of the publication which is
voices from people are incarcerated and
submissions and essays they've written
um and he was saying that he his battle
was to get those names onto the Masthead
so that they there would be this kind of
you know real recognition of the
contributions they were making anyway I
just had to add that little update it's
really
um interesting and you know reducing
people to there especially deciding that
the crime of their conviction has to be
the kind of tagline when that's not
something they're choosing
um is yeah kind of amazing and I guess
also not uh Caleb yeah well I wanted to
give at least a mention to Joy's volume
the new abolitionists which is
has this work that she's
describing and encourage people to read
the writers that are in that I also want
to tell a little bit about my experience
in
um discussing the 1858 prison Memoir the
life and the adventures of a haunted
convict
um which Joy wrote an incredible essay
about for Boston Review that's kind of
how we
first got to be in touch but um
the Reed wrote a retrospective Memoir of
his life in the 1850s and as I um
traveled around with that and um
describing his life and the conditions
he was also at Auburn State Prison that
I've just been describing which was the
birthplace of the
um the sort of
um penal servitude uh that did
eventually get enshrined in the 13th
Amendment that is it was Northern
Industrial penal servitude that was for
which an exception was made that then
came to be exploited by the southern
states in the in that re-enslavement
project because Auburn could not have
operated without this unwaged labor in
his workshops
um anyway the people as I discussed read
and his life story people is this goes
back also the question of genre or
fiction non-fiction kinds of narrative
the um crowds were very deeply preset
with two expectations one that his book
was a diary or Journal
rather than a retrospectively crafted
Narrative of his life so they wanted the
kind of access to the raw experience on
um unmanipulated by Art somehow uh and
two that he was innocent
neither of which was the case uh he
fully
um he described his participation in
crimes and um and uh never I mean he had
a kind of protest against the entire
system but on the specific grounds of
his own you know of his uh of this of
the accusation and sentencing there
wasn't a a disagreement
um and so that does seem to me uh to
speak to what you're saying about what
kinds of stories people expect on our
and are ready to endorse and this
question of Innocence that you raised
before and what kinds they don't want to
hear or they don't want to think of as
being you know on their side or
politically aligned with
um
I think that it also
um
and so there are truths that people
don't want told in this in this writing
um but the thing about the wanting it to
be a diary also suggests another kind of
pressure that's alongside that in some
awkward ways which is that
um incarcerated writers are always
supposed to talk about their own
experience as such
um and so there's a kind of like we're
not coming to them for their poetry or
whatever right um there's the
um this isn't I don't want your Artistry
you know I want the I want the kind of
Auto ethnography auto ethnographic truth
of this and read has an amazing moment
in his book where he talks about being
asked by a group of
um kind of anti-slavery uh wealthy white
liberals to recite some abolitionist
poetry for them which he does and
they're moved to tears
he recites a poem by the British
anti-slavery poet William Cooper
they give him money they offer to
support his education
and then a kind of aside to the reader
he says
I wonder what they would have said if I
recited some Outlaw ballads instead
right he's very sophisticated about what
kind of sympathy is available to him
um what this what kind of Charity case
he's being asked to play in that
situation and what the kind of like
white racial liberalism of that economy
is
and that he
carves out for him space another for
himself another kind to think of himself
as someone who could deploy many genres
as an artist who's capable of many kinds
of Storytelling and who could confront
them with something that they wouldn't
be so that wouldn't be so readily
acceptable
um
and I and I you know I'm I as as a
scholar of 19th century I'm routing a
lot of my answers back through this
historical stuff but I do think that
there is some continuity there you know
um the I would say there's the this
double bind of
tell us the truth but not too much
right
and I think joy that speaks to the
question you were asking about uh
prisoners who are writing a more 13th
Amendment based challenge to their
incarceration and um I wonder if that
for you brings up any other questions
about just like the limits of this kind
of communication I mean are we as a
obviously you know the the people who
are in charge of the prison environment
have an enormous amount of control over
what comes out unless people are able to
smuggle um images and writings out and
if you want to put your name on
something that you're writing then the
you know the the smuggling
um
Avenue is you can do it but then you're
going to be punished for it right and so
we're there
so I guess I wanna wondering about two
things so
um there is this real cost that someone
like sorry I forgotten the name of the
person you were referencing before who
was not able to get his writings out or
who's being put in Stevie Wilson Stevie
Wilson he had some of his work is that
but he's continuously harassed yes so
he's having this particular dilemma of
wanting to be the named author and the
work he's producing because it's his
creative mind that's producing it it's
his work
um it should have that recognition but
there's this incredibly clear cost to
bear so that's one sort of very
contemporary uh manifestation I think of
the limitations that Caleb was talking
about and then we're having this moment
where prisons are losing control over
some of the particularly photographs and
even videos that are coming out of these
environments because of the you know
cell phone culture in which people are
able to document their worlds and
um in the last several months the New
York Times other Publications have run
these incredibly disturbing set of
photos and images that you know people
within the walls took to document and
show what they were happening and the
reason those images can come out with
maybe a little more safety for the
people producing them is that they're
Anonymous and so their power is doesn't
you don't get to claim the ownership and
authorship of it
um anyway I just was thinking about
those things as you were talking yeah so
to cook things like the reason why Kayla
bike got into anthologizing I mean said
it elsewhere is that
um I was asked by Davis to do a
prototype for critical resistance and I
did at CU Boulder Colorado and then an
anthologized you know the academics and
in the intellectuals who were there
and I agreed with the press or asked to
press to send 50 copies inside and so I
was given a list of incarcerated people
including people who'd been in the
panther party and so one person who'd
been in the party wrote back
um again I say you know it's kind of a
joke on me you know I thought it was
being helpful that the book wasn't he
didn't say it wasn't that good he just
said thank you but you know it doesn't
really reflect
the conditions inside of long-term
detainees particularly those who came in
as political because they have Surplus
torture because the point is like we
don't just want to break you we want to
break your connection to these ideas
that make you think you could take on
the state right and so when I went to
Brown from there
all I did was anthologize right but also
people weren't ready for it so I left
eventually but when I was writing it
could be the Bergens who were you know
pacifists
um Daniel I can't remember one of them
had cancer and died inside so I think it
was fell up
um we're doing I'm sorry keep mixing up
the brothers they're Catholics who are
against the war in Vietnam they were
Catholic priests and then one of them
left the church right
um he was a contributor right and but
then you get letters back so the
consequences you get the letters back
from the prison officials that you're
trending towards illegal Behavior by
trying to get information from the
incarcerated about their perspective in
politics you get pushed back from the
University itself because they're not
ready for conferences where former like
Weather Underground you know Laura
Whitehorn or something come to campus
and speak like that was prohibited 20
years ago now it's okay so then one of
the things that comes into my mind I
mean maybe like I should take more naps
and not think this much but it seems
like what you couldn't do 20 years ago
with Rebels you can do now I have former
students
um when I was at Brown is teach courses
on the Panthers who you know they're
writers now they're doing a book or
other people are doing books on George
Jackson I could barely teach George
Jackson at Brown I mean my students went
on a verbal strike they sat in the class
for two hours and didn't say anything
because I signed George Jackson Soledad
brother and Frank walderson in the
beginning of his writings on
afro-pessimism right and it was you know
they were clever they were brilliant
they were ethically committed but it was
I think this is what you were saying
there's certain truths that nobody wants
to hear
it's not even that they're inconvenient
they're incompatible with Who We Are
but now there's more compatibility and
so I'm wondering if they're turning to
commodities
if past Rebels are now the Commodities
of the 21st Century
and if if we're going down that road
then what is rebellion against a
proto-fascist state
which the prison already is you're just
waiting for prison culture which is
already you know it's it's a parallel
mirror distorted one of increasingly
what happens at the borders you know
when you shoot people coming over
you know because they they're trying to
flee you know Devastation and
increasingly what's happening in
different sectors of society you know
Buffalo Uvalde
so
I mean it's these are way too big
questions they're giving me a headache
but I but they're constant and I don't
live the conditions they're people who
live the conditions of severe violence
who were thinking all the time
and then I think about it as an ally but
I'm not sure how steady my bridge is
over and I have no intention of being
implicated in anything so that I lose my
privilege or my standing
so those are some of like that's what I
meant about the ethics I'll say I'm a
good person so I have personal morality
do I what my political ethics are they
continue to shift I mean one last thing
is Kevin Johnson is supposed to be
executed in Missouri
next month on November 29th and so
people have asked us to help but you
know one I don't think it's Missouri I
don't think you can stop this but then
what could be said about his writings
so that we remember him if we can't keep
him alive
and I think that's just the basic bare
minimum that people make those are their
basic requests
that's I wonder if uh there's anyone in
the audience with a question they are
interested in asking I know it's always
hard to be the first person who asks a
question
um but it looks like I have some takers
um Peter I feel like your hand is up you
get the first question
I was very struck by by all sorts of
things but biracial phrase about being
condemned to religion the Bible
oh I was struck by Rachel's phrase of
being condemned to religion the only
book you can take into solitary is the
um is the Bible essentially uh which
aligns with uh the conversion narrative
that Caleb was talking about I think
back to an ancient genre I think starts
in the 17th century of the nougat
biography where the ordinary of nougat
who was the chaplain of the of a big
prison in in London uh took confessions
and autobiographies from convicts who
are about to be hung and he would
literally stand at the foot of the
Gallows and take their confessions and
then he'd write them up and publish them
and sell them for for Sixpence and he
made a handsome supplement to his salary
by doing this
so this is the moment
um of truth right and in which they have
to express Christian thoughts but it
makes them it gives them a kind of
posthumous glory in infamy because
they're supposed to detail all their
crimes but then tell how their crimes
led to their their moment of repentance
at the foot of the Gallows and so on so
there's some unhealthy uh connection
here it seems to be between conversion
infamy
um and uh and and publicity and and
profit of course because he's making
good profit on this and you you talked
about uh votram Balzac's great criminal
and there's this wonderful moment when
he converts to the police and what he
essentially says is there's no
difference between cops and Rogers
they're just two faces of the same thing
yeah okay yeah
um listening to you talk Peter I was
thinking also about
um Joy's referencing of uh the death
penalty
um
so like in this version where you're
allowed to confess or forced to confess
right before you go
I fortunately can't remember the name of
the person but somebody
um
somebody was executed just a couple
weeks ago and the last line of the
article was
um he said nothing when offered a final
comment
um you know before they I don't I can't
remember if he died by electrocution or
by injection one of those two methods
okay thank you very much Joe Nathan
James there was another execution uh
last summer I believe
unfortunately also like I'm nervous
about I don't remember the name of that
person either but what the the odd thing
that I remember about this other
execution is that the journalist who was
sent to report on it
um was told by the guards that her skirt
was not long enough and that it needed
to be exactly at the knee and not one
inch above it I believe it was half an
inch above her knee and so one of the
other one of the lawyers who was going
to be at that execution loaned her from
the trunk of his cars a pair of fishing
hip waders which she was allowed to wear
into this execution the reason I bring
this up is that it just speaks to the
absurdity of the bureaucratic apparatus
that attends to matters of life and
death involving people
um I think about that a lot how strange
that is I guess finally maybe I just
want to add
this this
um
that these conversions that these
confessions excuse me were sold uh
according to Peter is interesting to me
because it also maybe
reminds me of a point that maybe I keep
coming back to here this morning about
some desperate need on the part of a
free citizenry or those who manage a
free citizenry to keep separate those
who need to confess from those who might
possess a confession almost as a
talismanic reminder that they themselves
uh will not be entangled in that process
um he has this beautiful passage in this
remarks on Marx from 78 where he says
well of course all of my work has always
been fiction right how could you not do
fiction my historical work was fiction
of course historical facts you can check
them all you can do the kind of fact
checking for that work and for social
scientific work but threading it
together sewing it together right and
what you do with it is always an act of
fiction and in part we aren't willing I
mean that's true
are non-fiction is fiction our social
sciences are fiction
but we're not willing in part to accept
that because as academics we need to
protect ourselves from that from that
that cut
but in in truth it's true of Journalism
as well
everything is fiction and what that
means
is that everything is a political
engagement
yeah
yes why don't you have the last word
because I want to be respectful of the
time I'll open those things off no no
sorry I didn't mean to really intimidate
you go well I love what you've said but
I also fear that maybe like fiction is
the kind of dirty word there because it
suggests a string from truth although
that's PR you probably meant something
much more nuanced than that but I would
say like
fiction to me in a way is actually sort
of um back to your question is separate
from or safe from or protected from in a
sense the political
um because the writer herself when she
embarks on the project of reflecting the
world through the Grand and
hallucinatory mythical envelope that we
call the novel and started you know 200
years ago when she embarks on that
project she does not already have an
idea or an argument of what the problem
is nor what the solution is and rather
wants to reflect reality in its granular
detail to the best of her ability
so in that sense if she has somebody
who's in prison if they're in prison in
California probably they actually did
the thing that they were convicted of
and she's not going for what the reader
would like to hear which is that this
person is in fact innocence and she's
going to need to be able to ensnare some
of the absurdity of the institution like
they give you a handbook that's 30 pages
and then they give you a guide to the
handbook that's 140 Pages they want you
to read both
um I guess just well I don't want to
close so why don't you I just wanted to
um say that I I do think that the that I
see the novel as not necessarily
political that doesn't mean that I'm not
political I spent two years uh writing a
very long piece about prison abolition
for the New York Times magazine so
that's like a different set of tools
that I use on occasion but it's not the
novel so I just want can we say yes
please
yeah so again like thanks everybody but
I do want to Echo it spinstead I think
the politics are that's the stumbling
block
and also you know I believe in emotional
intelligence and so if you accept the
politics then you accept certain layers
of trauma even if it's secondary or
tertiary because you're not inside and I
think that also can sometimes inhibit
whether or not we will walk closer to
politics that are not popular
um so to shorten I would say I I create
two personas I do the political work I
use the academy to pay for me you know
my family and health insurance and then
I write Theory as an academic I do the
anthologies
as a side gig which is where my heart is
and that's that's the balance if you
want to call me a writer you know I'm
definitely an academic but anything I
edit is because
there's a relationship like all the
relationships that you express we all
have them
it's to show up to the relationship
which then becomes a form of politics
that seems like an I just like a note to
close on I feel like there are so many
ideas that we can spend the day
unpacking thank you so much Rachel and
Caleb enjoy thank you
[Applause]
[Music]